Ще зовсім недавно легкоатлетка Яна Максимова тренувалася у себе вдома в Білорусі.
Нині ж вона підтримує форму тут - у німецькому Дуйсбурзі.
Максимова зі своїм чоловіком спортсменом Андрієм Кравченком і півторарічною донькою
вирішили залишити Білорусь. У своїх соцмережах Яна написала,
що повертатися поки не збирається. Зокрема, і через ситуацію
з бігункою Христиною Тимановською на Олімпіаді в Токіо.
Після того, що сталося з Тимановською, я побачила реакцію наших керівників.
І я зрозуміла, що в країні абсолютно нікому буде, раптом що, мене захистити.
Наше керівництво не стане на мій бік. Мені чекати допомоги там буде абсолютно ні від кого.
І я оприлюднила такий пост, я точно вирішила, що мені зараз
в країну повертатися дуже небезпечно.
Думка про від'їзд з країни у подружжя назрівала давно.
Обидва активно брали участь у протестах, які спалахнули в країні після президентських виборів рік тому.
Кравченко був першим зі спортсменів, які підписали відкритий лист до влади
у серпні минулого року. Після цього його відрахували зі збірної.
У листопаді 2020 року його ще й затримали та засудили на десять діб.
На спортсмена продовжили тиснути.
До мене приїжджав міністр з двома дзюдоїстами. Він взяв з собою двох величезних дзюдоїстів.
Напевно, щоб залякати мене, щоб я припинив свою діяльність.
Він мені прямим текстом сказав: подумай про себе, про свою дружину,
про дитину. Куди ти лізеш? Припиняй.
Максимова і Кравченко - не єдині спортсмени, які залишили Білорусь протягом останнього року.
Найрезонансніший випадок - ситуація навколо легкоатлетки Христини Тимановської.
Білоруські функціонери відсторонили її від забігу на Олімпіаді в Токіо
і спробували насильно вивезти до Білорусі за критику спортивних чиновників.
Лише завдяки втручанню японської поліції і Міжнародного олімпійського комітету
Тимановській вдалося залишитися в Японії.
Явно давали зрозуміти, що по поверненню додому на мене буде чекати якесь покарання.
А якщо я раптом відмовлюся їхати додому і вийду на дистанцію 200 метрів
і пробіжу її, то, швидше за все, мене звільнять з роботи, виженуть з національної команди.
І були такі тонкі натяки, що цим справа не закінчиться.
Польща видала Тимановській гуманітарну візу, а Білоруський фонд спортивної солідарності
купив квиток на рейс Токіо-Варшава. Спортсменка вже прибула до Польщі,
але просити політичний притулок не збирається.
Я не думала зараз з приводу політичного притулку.
Все, що я хочу - це залишитися у спорті, продовжити свою спортивну кар'єру тут.
І ми обрали Польщу, бо я також спілкувалась з батьками, які сказали, що Польща
буде найкращим для мене варіантом, бо в них, можливо, вийде також сюди приїздити до мене,
щоб ми могли зустрічатися іноді.
На підтримку Тимановської виступили й інші білоруські атлети.
Зокрема, ті, хто був змушений залишити Білорусь ще раніше - плавчиня Олександра Герасименя
і срібний призер Олімпійських ігор з десятиборства Андрій Кравченко.
Я сам бігав 400 метрів, я знаю, що це таке.
І, в принципі, реакція адекватна. Провини Христини в цьому взагалі жодної немає.
Не вона ж винна, що естафета розвалилася і немає людей, щоб укомплектувати естафету.
Тому тут провина лежить на керівництві.
Спорт завжди відігравав важливу роль для Олександра Лукашенка.
Він до останнього домагався проведення в країні Чемпіонату світу з хокею.
За виступом же збірної на Олімпіаді в Мінську також пильно стежать багато білорусів.
І помилка, допущена керівництвом у випадку з Христиною Тимановською,
може дорого коштувати режиму, вважає Андрій Кравченко.
За рахунок спортсменів - там червоно-зелений прапор постійно миготить -
Лукашенко піднімає свою легітимність. Але, як ми бачимо, у нього це не дуже добре виходить.
Тому що цей режим сам себе і закопує.
Таких помилок припускатися на рівному місці...
Це звичайна дівчина, звичайна дівчина. Ну, не треба ж як маленькі дівчатка бігати,
ображатися, кричати, виганяти з Олімпіади.
Яна Максимова виграла Кубок Білорусі з багатоборства у червні цього року.
Спортсменка готувалася і до участі в Олімпіаді, але до збірної не потрапила.
У Німеччині вона сподівається продовжити спортивну кар'єру.
Я б дуже хотіла продовжити тренуватися.
Я б дуже хотіла завоювати медаль на зимовому Чемпіонаті Європи у семиборстві,
п'ятиборстві, неважливо. Якщо не вийде, то моє життя триватиме.
Я буду вивчати мову, влаштуюся на роботу.
Але тепер на першому місці у Максимової та Кравченка - безпека їхньої родини.
У Німеччині вони можуть залишатися, але поки - за тимчасовою візою.